[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
sur public sénat et retour ce matin à
l'audition de cédric au le secrétaire
d'état chargé du numérique
il s'est exprimé devant les sénateurs de
la commission des affaires économiques
notamment autour de ce projet
d'application stop qu'ovide cette
application de tra singh dont il a le
projet pour la période du déconfinement
et qui devrait permettre aux français de
savoir si l'on croisé dans les jours
précédant une personne qui pourrait
avoir eu le coc vide à l'heure face à
toutes les inquiétudes des sénateurs le
secrétaire d'état chargé du numérique a
tenté de rassurer cette application sera
installé sur la base du volontariat
les données seront parfaitement anonyme
le projet enfant est en open source et
il sera européen cela notamment face aux
inquiétudes des sénateurs qui craignent
pour la souveraineté numérique
néanmois ce projet d'application pose un
certain nombre de difficultés cédric
coll a reconnu notamment en termes tout
simplement de faisabilité on n'est pas
encore sûr de pouvoir lancer cette
application est aussi en matière
d'efficacité car il faudrait qu'au moins
deux tiers de la population puisse
utiliser cette application pour qu'elle
soit finalement efficace
retour donc à l'audition de cédric peau
je voudrais souhaiter la bienvenue à
leur sens de mes collègues et vous dira
tout ce que nous avons et les remercier
d'ailleurs que nous avons nous sommes
suivis dans cette discussion par une
dizaine de journalistes que je salue
amicalement que je remercie d'être là
nous poursuivons donc aujourd'hui les
auditions de contrôle de l'action du
gouvernement pendant cette période de
deux crises qui je le rappelle est avant
tout une crise sanitaire et nous avons
en chaque début d'audition et à chaque
fois que nous travaillons le sentiment
bien sûr important de travailler pour
l'économie mais de reconnaître que nous
sommes d'abord dans une crise sanitaire
notre commission vous le savez messieurs
ministre est pleinement mobilisée nous
avons auditionné vos vos collègues
ministres les principaux ministres qui
relève des compétences ce qu'ils sont
les nôtres et nous travaillons avec les
cellules de surveillance de veille
d'anticipation que nous avons mise en
place voici maintenant deux semaines sur
différents secteurs le tourisme la
culture le logement mais aussi
aujourd'hui le numérique
le président de la république a annoncé
hier soir la poursuite de la période de
confinement pour quatre semaines au
minimum
il a également annoncé ce qui nous
concerne en premier chef la poursuite et
l'amplification des mesures de soutien à
l'économie
vous êtes secrétaire d'état en charge du
numérique et avec cette crise la france
comme le reste du monde se met au 100%
numérique
j'aurai pour lancer le débat sur ce
sujet trois observations
premièrement cette épreuve offre à ce
secteur des opportunités incroyables
mais offre est présente également des
risques
du point de vue des risques force est de
constater premièrement nos faiblesses
dans ce secteur stratégique non
numériques colonies numérique les termes
ne manquent pas pour décrire la
situation que nous connaissons
c'est sur google sur facebook créé sur
twitter que nous recherchons les
informations sur les systèmes
d'exploitation apple d'apple et de
google comme sur fond et c'est en
californie que l'on profite de la crise
pour expérimenter la livraison par les
véhicules autonomes même au sénat
je dois dire nous peinons à trouver un
logiciel de visioconférence aussi
performant que celui sur lequel nous
sommes aujourd'hui zoom dont nous
connaissons pourtant les grandes foulées
plaît c'est les grands risques
les risques c'est que la crise
confortent hégémonie de ces géants et
selon un récent sondage neuf français
sur dix souhaitent une relocalisation
des entreprises industrielles
alors monsieur le ministre après la
crise le clan sera enfin devenu de
mettre en oeuvre une stratégie de
souveraineté numérique comme le
recommandait la commission d' enquête
sénatoriale présidée par franck montaugé
et je pense qu'il leur a à ce sujet des
questions à vous poser
toujours au niveau des risques la crise
touche de nombreuses startups du secteur
qui sont parfois durement touchée dans
une
pas de critique de leur décollage
économique vous me direz en quoi les
mesures adoptées par le gouvernement
sont adaptés à la situation particulière
de ces jeunes pousses qui sont bien sûr
l'avenir de notre industrie numérique
vous aviez annoncé en début d'année des
investissements qu'ils s'engageaient des
investisseurs institutionnels qui
s'engagerait à hauteur de 6 milliards
qu'en est il aujourd'hui en sont-ils de
ses engagements
du point de vue des opportunités le
développement du commerce électronique
est évidemment accélérées par la
fermeture des commerces physiques et par
les mesures de confinement si l'on ne
veut pas accepter opportunités ne
profite qu amazon il faut développer les
mesures d'accompagnement du petit
commerce par le commerce en ligne à
l'image de ce que fait par exemple la
poste avec ma ville mon shopping le
président de la poste nous en a parlé la
semaine dernière
la france est en retard sur la
numérisation des entreprises encore plus
s'agissant du commerce de proximité des
commerçants sont désormais pleinement
conscients ils font beaucoup d'efforts
depuis un mois pour rattraper les choses
les programmes de formation alors
adressent parfois des libertés sont
aujourd'hui plébiscités j'en veux pour
exemple
d'ailleurs au delà de la formation des
fonds que dédiait la région
ile-de-france sur l'aide à la
numérisation des commerces qui était un
peu boudé et qui aujourd'hui sont
plébiscités que fait le gouvernement
pour saisir de cette opportunité de nous
rattraper
deuxième point d'attention nous
constatons aujourd'hui que la crise
transforme la fracture numérique en
gouffre numérique tant au niveau des
réseaux bien sûr que des usages la
fracture numérique amplifier les
inégalités sociales les inégalités
territoriales c'est une grande
inquiétude bien sûr qui vient de nos
territoires je suis sûr que vous avez
adoré ce point mais aussi peut-être le
retard ou les difficultés dans le
déploiement que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui en raison des problèmes de
confinement
enfin troisièmement parmi les annonces
d'hier figure la consultation du
parlement sur l'application du traçage
qui est en cours de réflexion au sein du
gouvernement
je pense que de nombreuses questions
vous seront posées à ce sujet qui
couvrent des champs qui évidemment sont
sur des réflexions extrêmement large
mais je me permettrai une première
question il faudra que première marque
il me semble qu'il faudra que cette
saisine soit une véritable saisine du
parlement avec une étude d'impact qui
repose sur des analyses scientifiques il
faudra que ces saisines portent sur un
projet précis et détaillé qui pour
l'instant ne fait pas jour où il ya
beaucoup d'options ouverte il faudrait
que cette saisine faso suite à la
publication peut-être d'avis des
différents experts un minimum le conseil
d'état pour le droit à la cnil pour la
défense de la vie privée
conraud sujet est la cible pour la
cybersécurité
mais c'est le ministre pouvait vous vous
engagez à respecter ces conditions et
puis enfin j'ai une petite question
peut-être un peu impertinente mais qui
ne souhaitent pas être impertinente
qu'ils soient plutôt apporter des
clarifications
votre ministre de tutelle bruno le maire
a indiqué que ce n'était pas son
ministère qui était en charge de ce
développement de l'outil de traçage que
cela relevait plus du ministère de
l'intérieur et du ministère de la
défense
or on entend que vous-même secrétaire
d'état au numérique vous travaillez avec
de la santé sur ce sujet là alors pouvez
vous vraiment nous dire qui sont les
pilotes de ce sujet et comment la
saisine du parlement va être fait dans
les prochaines semaines voilà quelques
sujets qui seront bien sûr complété par
les questions de mes collègues mais je
vais d'abord vous laisser la parole
merci madame la présidente et sur les
sénateurs alors les sujets abordés
aujourd'hui c'était extrêmement divers
puisque de macro économique
l'un des problèmes de résilience des
réseaux passant par évidemment de ma
question là la question du numérique
combattre l'épidémie est bien évidemment
le sujet que je suivais plus particulier
de l'application péter le travail de je
vais essayer de ne pas être trop ou mais
que tu devrais donc de n'est pas
forcément à chaque fois exactement
détaillé afin de ne pas embaucher et
monopolisé la parole mais je suis
d'abord si on pour répondre à toutes les
questions posées
si on fait deux pas de recul même son
petit et vous avez eu tellement raison
de le souligner c'est que la crise révèl
est belle
il n'ya encore plus prégnante le cas
avant la crise
[Musique]
élément le premier élément c'est que le
numérique et la question de l'outil
numérique est devenue quelque part
l'épiné dorsale du fonctionnement de
notre société de nos institutions et de
nous
nos mécanismes de fonctionnement plus
beaux qu'ils soient derrière dans les
entreprises dans les institutions dans
une relation interpersonnelle et on a pu
toucher du doigt à quel point je pense
les français ont pu toucher du doigt à
quel point ce sujet elle a été un sujet
de vie quotidienne et de l influent et
le grand choix de la nation mais
également aujourd'hui sans les multiples
applications qu'ils se servent la vie
serait beaucoup moins supportable en
confinement et la capacité à continuer à
vivre à travailler fonctionner pour les
institutions seraient beaucoup plus
compliqué que serait-il si cette cette
audition en l'occurrence n'aurait pas pu
se tenir 118 de télésurveillance et le
parlement serait il est déjà il ya déjà
du mal à fonctionner mais normalement
mais ce serait encore pire sens et ses
outils et donc je pense que ça a révélé
quelque part le caractère demi vital du
numérique avec évidemment ce que vous
avez très fortement soutenir 7e ou un
certain nombre de sujets pas tous mais
la dépendance très forte de l'europe à
des outils geek un autre ce qui pose
beaucoup de questions nous le savions
être dans votre commission j'ai assez
profond
c'est sûr que dans la période sans les
entreprises américaines
beaucoup de choses serait plus compliqué
cette bio conférence en est un exemple
même si je puis me permettre de les que
les outils français voire européens
marchent presque aussi bien que zoom et
je marche extrêmement bien mais d'autres
outils peuvent permettre de remplir les
fonctions essentielles qui sont
amplifiées je pense que faut le
considérer j'ai vu que la commission
européenne avait interdit l'utilisation
de définir une doctrine mais pense qu'il
est important que nous ne savions pas
forcément tout ça vaut pour les teints
aussi l'expérience utilisateur qui est
le grand malheur du numérique c'est que
jean alors pour comprendre le film mon
intervention est revenu sur les
différents items de l'intervention des
sujets que vous souhaitiez que nous
abordions aujourd'hui divers sujets
peut-être d'abord et puisque nous
parlions de 2
question souveraineté revenir sur ce que
nous avons mis en place pour soutenir
l'écosystème numérique français puisque
évidemment la question va se poser de
faire en sorte que nous ayons des
options technologiques à disposition
encore faut-il à court terme que ces
options technologiques et les gens tu ne
disparaissent pas et que ce que nous
avons mis collectivement plusieurs
années à construire de manière
transparente isamu d'ailleurs ne
disparaissent pas au sein de la crise
pour des raisons d'emploi je rappelle
que nos systèmes numériques et les
startups devait compter pour la création
d'un train d'emplois sur cinq n'ont pas
sur six va évidemment se chiffre à ces
cas d'une solution économique mais ça
donne mais aussi pour des raisons
souveraine c'est que sur des questions
numériques tout comme sur les questions
de start up
nous ne pouvons pas laisser tomber cet
écosystème pour une raison simple je
prends une biotechnologie sur les
biotechnologies dont on voit toute
l'importance aujourd'hui plus ni moins
que de développer des vaccins ou de
développer des solutions pour lutter
contre une maladie qu il faut à peu près
dix ans et dix ans de recherche et donc
si aujourd'hui nous laissons tomber tout
ce tissu d'entreprises
alors nous mettrons dix ans à
reconstruire ce tissu qui est absolument
qui est absolument vital est donc un des
premiers axes de l'action que nous avons
eu c'est de faire en sorte de soutenir
ses entreprises
de la même manière dans le cadre du plan
des plans globaux qui ont été décidés de
soutien à l'économie mais ces
entreprises ayant une certaine
particularité notamment une relation un
peu plus distante avec l'éco système
bancaire parce qu'elles se financent
majoritairement sur denain privé et non
pas sur prêts faire en sorte qu'elle
puisse trouver l'accès au financement
c'est dans ce cadre que j'ai annoncé il
y à peu près deux semaines je crois un
plan de soutien notamment la trésorerie
mais de 4 milliards d'euros pour
soutenir les start up française qui
reposait sur plusieurs éléments d'abord
adaptation des critères généraux des
critères d'éligibilité aux prêts
garantis par l'état aux startups et ça a
été la prise en compte pour les
entreprises qui sont innovantes de la
masse salariale plutôt que du chiffre
d'affaires une biotech ne fait pas ce
chiffre d'affaires pendant dix ans elle
n'offrait pas est donc conditionné
limiter la capacité à faire un prêt à
1,2 fois le chiffre d'affaires fait deux
fois 000 et donc il fallait trouver un
autre critère est donc pour les
entreprises dans l'agglo cutter masse
salariale deux fois la masse salariale
de 19 d'ailleurs je le dis au passage
tout comme nous avons veillé à adapter
les critères du chômage partiel au
modèle de fonctionnement de ces
entreprises
c'est le premier événement faire en
sorte que ces entreprises puissent avoir
accès aux prêts à la garantie de 300
milliards d'euros sur les prêts garantis
par l'état pour une évaluation
est-ce que ça représentera d'à peu près
deux milliards d'euros la question des
beautés puisque forcément aisé d'avoir
chiffré précis mais nous avons fait que
ce serait à peu près de 2 milliards
d'euros
c'est l'annoncé du versement anticipé
d'un certain nombre bed
[Musique]
mais surtout déchire et donc les start
up
déjà bénéficié pour celles qui le
demande d'un versement aujourd'hui du
cir 2019 alors que ces versements arrive
normalement tobre ce qui leur permet
d'anticiper de six mois des crédits de
trésorerie absolument important ce qui
représente en additionnant le cir et le
pré versement d'un certain nombre de
tranches il ya sur les aides à
l'innovation
un peu moins de 2 milliards d'euros là
encore et enfin c'est un certain nombre
de dispositifs importants vous savez que
ces entreprises se financent sur eux
levée de fonds avec général et que pour
celles qui devaient lever des fonds et
est en train de lever des fonds devaient
les foudres de lever des fonds à court
terme
celle ci pouvait rencontrer un certain
difficulté la situation d'un créneau
économique et donc nous avons mis en
place un système de financement
spécifiques en termes de prêts qui à la
bpi qui co-investit ray avec les
investisseurs historiques ont donné un
peu d'air à ses entreprises telle
manière qu'elle puisse survivre le temps
de pouvoir après la crise tout ceci sans
préjuger du fait que évidemment des pays
france qui est un acteur majeur de
l'innovation en france continuera de la
même manière qu'ils offrent à déployer
des crédits sur 2020 ce qui représente
au total près de 3 milliards d'euros qui
seront injectés pardon en 2020 dans les
systèmes système français pour peut-être
chiffres que je n'ai pas encore donné
publiquement mais faire un petit point
d'étape sur le recours à un ensemble de
ces outils notamment sur les prêts de
trésorerie jour le jour en fin de
semaine dernière sur les prêts de
trésorerie
j'ai vu que j'évoquais c'est près de
8500 start up qui ont eu un pré accord
pour un montant de 1,2 milliard d'euros
et sachant que comme vous savez
préaccord la vente privée ensuite
l'accord de garantie de bp et donc je
vous donne le montant il ya eu le pré
accord de la banque un certain nombre de
données sont en cours d'instruction
mais ça vous donne une idée volume de
soutien l'écosystème qui est on les
tuyaux je répète 8500 start up pour
prêts pour des montants de prêt peut
sans préjuger de ce qui viendra de la
suite tout de suite puisque nous sommes
pas encore dans la presse évidemment
comme j'ai eu l'occasion de le préciser
cette crise montre à quel point un la
politique qui était celle du
gouvernement avant la crise qui était de
1,6 t énormément sur texte numérique et
technologique qui a parfois été un peu
raillé sous le terme de start up mais
jeunes est évoqué comme un projet un peu
ésotérique qui ne concernait pas tous
les français
la crise d'aujourd'hui montrent à quel
point avec concerne tous les français et
que dans le jeu au jour le jour
que ce soit pour la visioconférence et
applications de conversations email le
cloud ou encore énormément de visages
quotidien nous n'avons quasiment pas le
choix de faire en sorte de passer par
des entreprises américaines ce qui est
un problème non pas que les entreprises
américaines soit me reste en nature mais
le fait que nous n'ayons pas le choix
est assez révélateur il peut-être
démunis dans lequel qu'elles nous sont
nous sommes ce qui n'est pas vrai dans
tous les secteurs et je cite notamment
le cas
la télémédecine pour le gru le fait de
disposer d'un acteur français
extrêmement résilient et extrêmement
puissant qui pose par ailleurs d'autres
questions je le sais dans le dico mais
en tout cas a permis de passer d'un an
de téléconsultation de 10000 par semaine
à 490 il en deux semaines il faut se
rendre compte de ce que cela veut dire
et il est probable que sans un acteur
majeur capable d'encaisser ce choc là
nous n'aurions pas été capables de faire
cette transformation est donc j'appelle
qu'aujourd'hui s'agissant purement des
start up nous avons cette entreprise
licorne sans ce pur du terme
quatre qui sont devenus licorne depuis
un an ce qui montrait que la politique
efficacité
la question se pose évidemment d'aller
dire comment l'europe peut aller encore
plus loin
après la crise je lui dis aujourd'hui ça
ne se fera pas du jour au lendemain le
retard technologique prix dans certains
domaines est très important il ne peut
pas se combler du jour est en jeu
souhaitons fortement que cette crise
sert de révélateur et de prise de
conscience je crois que le président
hier soir évoqué la souveraineté
numérique dans les questions qui se
posaient pour lui évidemment à nous
poser la question collectivement
revenir sur d'autres sujets que je
souhaitais évoquer aujourd'hui vous les
avez évoqué au delà de cet aspect
écosystémiques
il y a eu dans les priorités des
premiers jours et des premières semaines
eric la nécessité de faire en sorte que
quelque part les infrastructures tienne
puisque il n'aurait rien eu de pire
entre guillemets s'agissant numériques
tels que les français confinés chez eux
voient leurs infrastructures tomber
termes d'infrastructures je parle bien
évidemment des réseaux internet qu'ils
soient fibre ou télécoms en tout cas
réseaux mobiles et cela a été un travail
extrêmement acharné de la part des
équipes en lien avec les opérateurs pour
faire en sorte que nous ne connaissions
pas la situation qu'a connu l'italie en
partie ralentissement des réseaux et
réseaux internet lié à l'augmentation
très significative de la consommation
puisque les gens confinés chez eux
d'abord télétravail de réseau et puis un
certain nombre d' usage de consommation
et de loisirs qui font que le réseau
très surchargé donc je ne rentre pas
dans les détails nous avons connu une
augmentation significative consommation
quelques problèmes notamment sur le
réseau mobile localiser et qui tuent été
réglés d'ailleurs c'était sur la voie
comme sur la question et grâce à un
certain nombre de mesures
prophylactiques que ce soit mme agissant
sur les réseaux eux mêmes sur les
interconnexions demande en gros
fournisseurs de contenus très fortement
de consommateurs de prendre un certain
nombre de mesures de dégradation de la
qualité des vidéos par exemple ou
s'agissant de disney plus puisque le
sujet et public de repousser la sortie
pourrait enfin en demandant aux français
de prendre un certains nombres réflexes
comme de privilégier le wifi sur le
réseau mobile sommes à peu près
aujourd'hui on peut dire que la
situation est stabilisée qu'il n'y a pas
d'inquiétude
généralisée qu'il peut y avoir de temps
en temps quelques petits problèmes
ponctuels mais que les choses sont sont
stabilisées et que estimons que nous
pourrons aller jusqu'à la fin du
confinement sans qu'il y ait de problème
majeur
de toute évidence cela pose et met en
lumière de manière encore plus cruel si
j'allais dire deux sujets premièrement
la sujet des zones blanches et la
couverture numérique du territoire
savoir le déploiement du réseau
qui il faut bien le dire a été percuté
de plein fouet par la crise du corps
d'un virus une des priorités du
gouvernement et dans les derniers jours
a été de permettre aux entreprises
opérateurs de continuer un d'être en
position de maintenir le réseau d'abord
de maintenir le réseau existant était la
priorité des priorités est ensuite de
continuer à déployer que ce soit la
fibre de réseaux mobiles
le bt oblige à dire que eux cela leur
est compliqué pour plusieurs raisons
pour une première raison qui est que
l'ours d'or structure leur opérateur
leurs techniciens de maintenance sont
eux-mêmes impactés par le confinement
par les maladies par la peur ce qui est
totale et la quiétude qui est
compréhensible des riffauds il faut
saluer courage et le dévouement de ces
populations qui permettre aux autres de
continuer à vivre chez eux et à
travailler pour d'autres raisons qui est
qu'ils sont que
mais il imagine qu'un certain nombre de
sénateurs le savent bien
dans les collectivités territoriales le
fait même que les personnels des péris
ne soit plus dans les mairies qu' il ya
un certain nombre d'arrêtés qui ont qui
interdisent les travaux publics a pu
continuer à poser certains problèmes de
déploiement et donc résolvons au cas par
cas si on ne résoud avec les opérateurs
au cas par cas le lien avec les
collectivités territoriales pour
permettre aux techniciens de l'opérateur
circuler c'est aussi indispensable pour
permettre de continuer les travaux ont
le cas échéant
quand vous faites une demande de travaux
ou qu'à une demande de travaux qui
arrive à échéance qu'elle puisse les
travaux puissent avoir lieu même si
quelques par les services de la
collectivité à la recevoir parce que
sinon c'est c'est tout le déploiement de
la fibre qui s'arrête et est évident que
sujet est encore
sujet également nous avons été
extrêmement clairs avec l'arcep avec les
opérateurs c'est de faire en sorte que
plus rapidement possible
au lendemain de la table de confinement
règlement de cette crise de déploiement
de la fibre puisse reprendre au même
rythme qu'il était celui d'avant qui je
le rappelle est le rythme le plus élevé
du monde puisque par jour ouvré en 2019
de connections 19 mai d'habitation 19
mille habitations par jour qui étaient
connectés à la fibre il n'existe aucun
pays dans le monde dans lequel si
important et l'objectif est bien de
faire la france l'un des pays les mieux
fleuries du monde mais il faudra faire
en sorte de revenir sur ce rythme le
plus rapidement possible puisque
donc c'est aujourd'hui la double peine
pour les personnes voilà voir la triple
peine pour les personnes qui n'ont pas
accès et évidemment au delà de la
question need you may et puis
particulier hachée se pose la question
de la fraction des usages tous ceux qui
ne se sentent pas à l'aise avec eric et
cela devra faire dans le cadre de ce qui
pourrait être un mouvement sans
précédent de mai à niveau numérique de
la france dans l'après crise il faut
réfléchir à la question de la formation
des gens toutes les personnes qui se
sentent éloignés du numérique sera un
élément extrêmement important sur la
question du système d'information jeu
petit pas de côté c'est évidemment le
sujet des systèmes d'information de
l'état et qui de toute évidence
n'avaient pas été anticipées comme
beaucoup de choses pour cette cette
période qui ont connu certaines
difficultés
je pense par exemple au premier jour des
espaces de travail numérique de
l'éducation nationale je crois qu'il la
réaction globale des services et a été
assez remarquable est que les choses
sont rentrées dans l'ordre
graduellement avec une mobilisation très
forte je cite ici mais nous avons été
très contents également s'agissant des
serveurs qui accueillait les outils de
l'éducation nationale de pouvoir compter
sur des entreprises françaises qui
avaient savoir faire qui fait le lien
avec la question de la souveraineté et
qui ont pu en quelques jours
leur montée en compétence e éducation
nationale dans la capacité à encaisser
le choc des connexions et donc je pense
qu'il faut un salué le travail notamment
de la direction du miracle de l'état qui
a été four et au moulin pour accompagner
les ministères salué le travail des
ministères qui ont su se mettre à niveau
de toute évidence
7 2 le système d qui a prévalu dans
l'urgence ne peut pas être une solution
solution de long terme et il faut se
poser la question notamment dans le cas
où cette crise sanitaire aurait des
répliques d'autres temps d'aimer
arriverait fonctionnement numérique de
nos institutions
je pense par exemple à tout ce qui
touche à l'état à l'éducation nationale
à la santé
j'évoquais tout à l'heure le chiffre du
nombre de consultations de télémédecine
passé de 10000 à 490 il en deux semaines
mais également et là c'est aussi du
fonctionnement parlement vous êtes les
premiers à souffrir de la difficulté qui
a pour des raisons techniques mais aussi
pour des raisons juridiques a fonctionné
à distance il me semble que une urgence
et ça je me permets 2 de l'évoquer mais
c'est à vous juger serait de faire en
sorte que si une nouvelle pandémie 1
revient l'année prochaine le parlement
puisse continuer à fonctionner parce que
c'est lui qui permet des coincés tous
les problèmes pour les autres et donc
dès lors qu'il faut prendre des lois en
urgence dès lors qu'il faut permettent
de modifier la législation de prendre
des mesures
c'est très handicapant que puissent pas
voter par exemple à distance des
premiers éléments à la capacité de nos
institutions à avoir une résilience qui
permettent de fonctionner à distance
nous ne l'avions pas prévu personne ne
pouvait le prévoir
je pense que maintenant il faut tenir
compte et dernier élément et je ne serai
pas plus long jamais été beaucoup qui a
trait à votre question je n'oublie pas
question avait posé mais je n'ai plus
large
c'est la question de l'utilisation du
numérique pour combattre l'épidémie
le sujet a été extrêmement
focalisé sur la question de
l'application stable que vides j'aurai
l'occasion mais quelque part
d'applications stable que vide sur
lequel il ya encore des interrogations
sur eux à la fois la faisabilité
technique et l'insertion et l'efficacité
dans une stratégie de déconfinement
n'est que la partie émergée de
l'ensemble de ce que nous faisons à
l'aide du numérique pour aider à
combattre l'épidémie et les outils
numériques ont été en première ligne
c'est en deuxième ligne de la gestion et
la capacité à combattre l'épidémie
que ce soit pour prévoir son évolution
faciliter cette détection faciliter
l'évaluation des cas graves et gérer
l'épidémie je vous donne quelques
exemples
d'abord l'exemple de maladie coronaire
il se pourrait faire qui est en gros un
site sur lequel les français il a invité
les français à aller lorsqu'ils ont des
symptômes avant d'appeler le 15
donc il ya une trentaine de questions
vos antécédents ces anonymes mais vous
renseigner vos antécédents votre poids
vos symptômes et on vous dit quelles
sont les clefs l'attitude à adopter soit
appeler le 15
soit appelez votre médecin traitant soit
attendre parce que ce n'est pas si grave
et je le cite parce que cela a permis
deux choses d'abord significativement
désengorger les appels au 15
en ile-de-france le nombre d'appels non
pertinent c'est à dire d'appel qui ne
sont pas des appels d'urgence mix bgi
team de gens qui ont des questions
att a été extrêmement extrêmement
descendu et a permis de désengorger le
parce que les gens qui se posaient des
questions sur g11 simples tels symptômes
tels symptômes et je supplie
asthmatiques trouver une réponse
automatique sans avoir besoin d'un pull
15 d'exemple danger le 15 et deuxième
chose ça permet de voir en direct
l'évolution de l'épidémie de manière
agrégée par le nombre de personnes qui
consultent le site et par compte tenu
des codes sociaux qui les lie gens là
l'endroit où celle est l'endroit où
l'épidémie évolue ça donne c'est au
total 4 millions de formulaires qui ont
été en plus sur maladie co2 deuxième
élément sur lequel numérique est
extrêmement utile c'est toutes les
applications de télémédecine et
télésurveillance
de toute évidence la télémédecine est
indispensable vous allez voir votre
médecin est un facteur de risque
et pour lui vous
et j'ai évoqué les chiffres
d'augmentation consultation de routine
va au delà de ça c'est la généralisation
de la télésurveillance la
télésurveillance médicale c'est qui a
permis de désengorger l'hôpital comme
vous le savez au début de l'épidémie
lorsque vous aviez locaux vides 19 même
sens et que vous présentiez les
symptômes
pas très grave vous n'étiez pas vous
restiez à l'hôpital compte tenu de
l'engorgement et de l'arrivée de
l'afflux énorme de patients c'est ceci
qui ont signé aujourd'hui c'est
notamment le cas de l'ap-hp lorsque vous
êtes diagnostiqués positifs
vous êtes et que mais que vous n'avez
pas de symptômes qui laisse présager
d'une issue grave vous invite à
télécharger l'application co vie d'homme
il en existe d'autres dans les autres
centres hospitaliers ou vous renseigner
chaque jour vos constante aux symptômes
qui permet d'avoir
un surveillance à distance extrêmement
précises de tous ceux qui ne sont pas là
et en fonction et symptômes que vous
déclarez pas mal de rythme vous suggère
de faim soit prévient les soignants soit
vous suggère d'appeler de prendre un
rendez vous médical ou alors d'appeler
appeler le 15 qui permet de désengorger
l'hôpital et deux par ailleurs là aussi
grâce à la remontée des données suivre
là et les sur des grandes masses les
symptômes et les évolutions de
l'épidémie l'évolution de ces symptômes
ce qui a permis notamment évaluer la
prégnance de quand on perd le goût quand
on perd le dorat partie grâce à sa
maladie coronaire risques on a vu
l'explosion de ces symptômes que les
médecins sentait et ce qui permet ce qui
permettra puisque c'est ce sur quoi nous
travaillons et c'est le dernier sujet
c'est la question de l'intelligence
l'utilisation de l'intelligence
artificielle et du big data qu'elle est
extrêmement importante pour être capable
de lier
dans l'urgence parce que c'est ça le
problème est sur une maladie que nous
connaissons pas
et symptômes
des cas de maladie des cas d'aggravation
de la maladie avec des historiques
médicamenteux ou des historiques de
pathologie et de pouvoir découvrir les
commodités les associe des interactions
médicamenteuses ou des associations des
associations non évidente soit de
médicaments soit de pathologies ce qui
nécessite à un moment d'avoir des
données agrégées de pouvoir croiser des
bases de données
bien évidemment en respectant les
données d'avoir des très très grosse
base auquel vous êtes capable de mener
des études épidémiologiques un des
études de sanitaires et épidémiologiques
en faisant tourner des algorithmes
d'intelligence artificielle en essayant
de découvrir des choses pour essayer de
courir le plus vite possible on des
interactions médicamenteuses que vous ne
vérifiez pas dans si vous n'aviez qu'il
ya des échantillons de sang de cent
mille patients et qui va jusqu'à je cite
par exemple un très beau projet sur
lequel hôpital cochin travail qui est un
projet de capacité à partir de dix mille
scanner thoracique de détection
automatique et cas graves du coc vie de
vous faites remonter dix mille scanner
thoracique à noter on sait que tel
scanner thoracique a mal terminé
on a développé ensuite un certain nombre
de problèmes
faites tourner des algorithmes qui
regardent des schémas et qui découvrent
eux
en fait on n'avait pas vu mais c'est
aider les médecins à la décision sur tel
cas tels cas pour enfin éventuellement
caractérisé le coc u19 sur le scanner
thoracique de manière plus facile voire
identifier les cadavres c'est un cas par
exemple qui est en cours de déploiement
et un énormément comme ça évidemment la
plupart ans a piloté par l'institut
pasteur
ce que nous essayons de faire c'est de
faire en sorte que tout cela ou verges
et le bon accès aux données
et là encore il faudra réfléchir et
réfléchir à notre fonctionnement mais
évidemment si mode de fonctionnement
probablement trop lents pour ces cas de
crise dans les moments où il faut savoir
vite la recherche
dernier élément ses réflexions que nous
avons sur stratégie de déconfinement à
la manière dont les outils pourraient
venir et b à la stratégie de
déconfinement et nous sommes sujets
évoqués plus précisément qui a fait la
une de l'application stop&go vide alors
pour répondre à votre question il y a
deux ministères en charge de ces outils
son secrétariat d'état eric et le
ministère de la santé
je veux être extrêmement clair
extrêmement précis ministère de
l'intérieur fait partie du gouvernement
évidemment ils tenus au courant comme
tous les ministres ont tenu vendredi
dernier et les équipes qui sont
impliqués sont des équipes en u13 est
ministre il ya deux autres ministères
qui sont impliquées qui sont lucerne la
justice évidemment recherche
je me suis fait une régate les pilotes
geste peu vite escaut tutelle de ce
quota cherche et jour le jour et
fonctionnellement
c'est un copilotage d'olivier ferrand et
de moi même sur une équipe qui rassemble
des équipes des équipes la santé sur le
travail sur les outils de déconfinement
sur les outils sanitaires il n'ya pas
supervision c'est à l'intérieur aucun
cas d'autres responsabilités de télé ce
sujet là d'abord parce que ce sont des
outils s'alternent j'insiste vraiment
sur ce sujet là il n'y a pas d'outil 2
vérification du respect du confinement
de kiki son ski sur lesquels nos voisins
européens travaillent sur des
applications et de sanitaires et de
prévention de lui nous associons nicole
belloubet son ministère évidemment
puisqu'il est question
ils sont au coeur de l'action en
quelques mots sur sur ce projet sur
lequel précédent d'un public l'a précisé
hier
je ne sais pas encore exactement sous
quelle forme et devra donner lieu à un
débat parlementaire sur une présentation
des options et un débat parlementaire
comme s'y est engagé avant la paix
d'autisme
de quoi s'agit-il
[Musique]
c'est d'abord un projet européen qui co
portée par la france l'allemagne et la
suisse
piloté par le pfl pour la suisse enfin
un train de faire en particulier
inria pour la france l'objectif est de
développer une application qui permet de
prévenir les personnes qui ont été en
contact avec une personne testée covit
plus de telle manière à ce qu'elles
puissent aller se faire tester les
objectifs et lequel l'objectif est de
travailler dans la perspective du
déconfinement la perspective de
déconfinement et et comme le président
l'a dit dédé confinement se fera un
moment où la maladie aura
significativement la prime dans un dé la
priorité afin d'éviter la maladie
repartent
et puis développeurs afin d'éviter que
nous devions re confiné pour le dis là
la priorité sera d'identifier
extrêmement vite eu les cas qui sont
testés positifs
et les personnes qui sont qu'à contacter
c'est-à-dire à risque c'est ce qui s'est
fait au stade 1 et 2 de l'épidémie
notamment l'épisode contamines montjoie
ou dès que des personnes ont été
identifiées comme testée positive
équipe entière 207 santé france prenez
contact avec elle ce modèle vous appelez
et mener des interviews extrêmement
poussé à savoir avec qui vous avez été
en contact quelles sont leurs fans ou
est-ce que vous êtes passé est-ce que
vous avez pris un avion et dans ce cas
là il faut prévenir tous les passagers
l'avion est mené l'historisation à la
main de cas contacts qui pouvaient être
qu'après et et priant avec lesquels
étaient pris contact c'est ce qui
d'ailleurs est la grande réussite des
modèles allemands et coréens espèces
c'est à dire que les modèles allemands
est rien notamment coréen
il ya une espèce de fantasme
technologique sur ce qu'a fait la corée
pour avoir une occasion d'en discuter
avec nos conseils scientifiques qui
beaucoup regardez ce qu'a fait la corée
eux le boutis technologique est venu en
surplus d'un dispositif de contact
racing à la main qui est extrêmement
efficace avec plusieurs centaines de
personnes étaient entièrement dédié à sa
agir extrêmement vite c'est ce que font
aujourd'hui les allemands ça évidemment
un lien avec la capacité à tester très
vite mais l'application de contacts
si beaucoup a vocation à venir en plus
de ce travail là et en complément ce
travail là
j'insiste beaucoup parce que c'est il ne
faut pas le voir comme la solution
magique je vais revenir après sur les
questions de libertés publiques
il faut le voir comme un outil qui peut
potentiellement aider au déploiement
enfin à la pala a cassé les chaînes de
transmission identifiées et casser les
chaînes de transmission et elle ne se
conçoit que dans une stratégie globale
est prioritaire de tests de mesure
d'isolement et c est donc c'est la
manière dont nous bleus dans nous
l'abordons
je répète que la décision de déploiement
d'application n'a pas été prise que ce
qui a été pricée la décision de
développer un prototype en lien avec les
allemands pour une raison simple les
contraintes et les difficultés
technologiques de déploiement de cette
application ne sont sont non
négligeables
il n'est pas certain ayons une
application qui marchent
technologiquement pour des raisons sur
lesquelles pourront venir si vous le
souhaitez et donc nous avons nous
assumons avoir décidé de lancer le
travail sur cette application pour
qu'elle soit à disposition dans les
semaines qui viennent si jamais nous ne
sommes nous jugeons si jamais elle est
jugée et il paraît si jamais après le
débat avec utiliser quelque part des
mesures d'anticipation et je pense qu'il
faut assumer
c'est le cas du moment assumons
pleinement fait que les outils
technologiques utiles aux de confinement
doivent être sur la table et utilisable
et des outils français pour faire le
lien avec la question de souveraineté
numérique que vous exposez début s'ils
devaient être jugés si nous devions jugé
que cet outil était utile aux
déconfinement
ce serait un petit peu gênant du point
de vue je pense de la représentation
nationale que les seuls outils qu'ils
soient sur la table soit 18,6
singapouriens américains voire allemand
pense qu'il est important français qu il
ya évidemment une condition sinequanone
de développement de ses outils et je
crois avoir été une gouvernement
réellement le président hier soir
extrêmement clair sur ce sujet c'est que
pour que c'est utile soit déployée mais
si utiles soient adoptées contenu de la
culture française
il faut qu'il respecte pleinement nos
valeurs et nos lois concernant
l'informatique
concernant la vie privée et les libertés
publiques et ce sera le cas j'ai eu
l'occasion de se dire ces outils seront
complètement aligné avec la législation
en vigueur et ne nécessiteront pas de
nouvelles dispositions et j'ose même
dire qu'ils seront mieux disant je
reviens sur les garanties que nous avons
mis sur la table qui sont des points de
départ qui sont l'installation
volontaire de l'application évidemment
partant la désinstallation personnes
concernées la deuxième chose qui est le
complète anonymat de ces données la
seule chose que fera cette application
c'est qu'elle vous préviendra si vous
avez été en contact dans les jours
précédents avec quelqu'un qui s'est
testée kovy de plus depuis
mais personne n'aura accès à la liste
des personnes contaminées les
réplications et personne n'aura accès à
qui a rencontré qui j'ajoute que l'on
parle bien l'historisation les relations
des pontes de la proximité sociale ehpad
entre hakim de la géolocalisation c'est
pour ça que le terme tracking s'en
passer approprié il n'y a pas de venir à
pas d'utilisation des données
téléphoniques et d'utilisation données
gps comment cela fonctionnera vous et
moi avons un téléphone
si nous avons tous les deux applications
un choc si nous restons à proximité dans
une certaine mesure je ne sais pas si
c'est one pendant plus de cinq minutes
aux épidémies de lire elle pourra en
fonction de 1
dans votre téléphone dans mon téléphone
sans registre le fait que nous avons été
en relation si demain je suis testé
positif je déclare probablement bien
avec l'aide d'un tiers de santé pour
éviter les déclarations au visible que
j'ai été testés positifs et vous recevez
une notification qui vous dit vous avez
été quand contact dans les jours
précédents avec quelqu'un qui a été qui
a été depuis testé positif veuillez vous
faire tester vous ne savez pas qui est
ce qui vient l'alertent je ne sais pas
qui enregistre dans mon téléphone et je
ne sais pas à qui j'ai envoyé le 10
questions personne ne sait j'insiste sur
ce point parce que il n'ya aucune
liberté publique aucune liberté publique
qui est remise en cause par cette
application dont d'ailleurs les données
sont effacées régulière je sais pas si
toutes les deux les trois semaines mais
conservera pas les donner l'application
elle même sera temporaire et donc par
ailleurs garantie du caractère
le caractère protecteur des libertés et
le fait qu'elle sera open source et que
donc
mises à la disposition de tout le monde
donc code sera mise à disposition de
tout le monde jugeait du fait qu'elle
fait bien ce que nous proposerons toutes
les garanties de transparence
c'est absolument indispensable c'est
indispensable
parce que c'est une valeur notre
sensibilité française sociale parce que
je pense que si cette application est
jugé utile un des défis sera la capacité
à déployer largement cette application
peut-être y revenir et cette question de
la fracture numérique et la rupture
d'équipement et nous met déjà avec des
gens qui ont un smartphone 80% à faire
en sorte que si cette application est
jugé utile et si cette application
valeurs et notre droit alors elle puis
celle de plus largement diffusée puisque
ce sera un bénéfice individuel pour le
porter et un bénéfice sanitaire pour la
collectivité dont nous parle je je
un dernier mois sur ce dernier point sur
ce sujet open source il est évident que
c'est un sujet de transparence c'est
également me semble-t-il un sujet de
j'allais dire diplomatie européenne je
trouve pour ma part que c'est un très
beau projet européen que de développer
une telle application
en commun entre des pays européens de la
rendre open source et de la mettre à
disposition de tous les pays qui
pourraient en avoir besoin
c'est quelque part un commun numérique
qui est produit par les européens à
destination des pays qui n'ont peut-être
pas la capacité à déployer ce genre
d'applications et si c'est utile
cela permettra à ces pays de d'avoir le
choix
un outil qui respectent nos valeurs les
valeurs universelles de liberté et de ne
pas être forcé de recourir à d'autres
outils qui ne les respectent peut-être
pas je pense que nous avons là une
espèce de commandes numériques qui
encore une fois s'il est utile est un
beau projet européen et que sous clair
je ne serai pas beaucoup plus long j'ai
déjà été assez je crois je perds mais ce
petit tour d'horizon qui a peu près les
divers sujets pas tous les sujets merci
beaucoup monsieur nous donner la parole
à franck montaugé monsieur le ministre
je vous laisse répondre ensuite aux deux
premiers interlocuteurs 30 franke ger
fardeau que j'avais pas appuyer sur le
ministre je voulais vous vous interrogez
sur les enseignements politiques au
nouveau que vous tirez en matière de ce
n'était du mérite de la nation à partir
de l'observation des comportements que
certains acteurs comme les gars femme
après année comme une opportunité de
développement et d'hégémonie
supplémentaires et vous avez un bonne
partie répondu répondu à cette question
que je qualifierais de général alors je
voudrais vous entre un petit peu dans
les détails
apple et google qui sont on le sait en
situation de duopole sur les marchés des
smartphones des magasins d'applications
mais des systèmes d'exploitation ont
annoncé dans un premier temps qu'ils
allaient développer une api permettant
l'interopérabilité opérabilité entre les
appareils android et ios et qu'ils
allaient collaborer pour faciliter le
fonctionnement des zapa des applications
gouvernementales de tracing bluetooth et
dans un second temps ils vont très
probablement proposer leurs propres
applications
c'est normal c'est leur leurs objectifs
et d'entreprises la question du lait
mais question simple est ce que vous ne
craignez pas que ces jeunes se substitue
une fois de plus aux états souverains et
pouvez-vous nous assurer que la solution
que vous adopterez sera totalement
souveraine et donc hermétique au moins
deux recueils de données par toute
entreprise étrangère
voilà mes deux premières questions sur
la sur la mise en oeuvre du stock co
vide que vous avez abordé
est-ce que vous pouvez nous assurer que
la solution que vous adopterez peut-être
la solution européenne est que vous avez
évoquées si elles devaient être mises en
oeuvre s'accompagnerait de campagne de
tests massive sans quoi cette
application ne serait d'aucune utilité
la technique fut-elle très performante
en elle-même ne pourra pas résoudre la
question évidemment de l'art et la pop
une propagation du virus
il pouvait vous vous engagez à conduire
rendent toute généralisation une
expérimentation
après j'avais une dernière question pour
pour terminer qui a rapport à la
solidarité qu'on aimerait voir se
développer de la part vigia numérique on
ne constate que depuis le début du
confinement
les entreprises dont l'activité est
essentiellement numérique tire en
réalité très bien leur épingle du jeu
on entend des appels à la sonorité hamdi
envers certains secteurs je pense en
particulier aux assurances c'est bien
normal mais pas en direction des
entreprises utilisant le numérique
monsieur le ministre alors que la caq
sbires femme a été suspendu cette année
n'est ce pas le moment d'appeler ces
derniers a certes comme le solidarité
par exemple un abondant généreusement le
fonds de solidarité pour les entreprises
tous les français continuent de surfer
sur google sur facebook etc
le cours de bourse d'amazon a presque
retrouvé son plus haut niveau historique
avait été atteint fin février
ne serait-il pas bienvenu de leur
demander un geste de solidarité
conséquent je vous remercie
merci franck est pour peut-être complété
la deuxième question de franck sur
l'entente entre apple et android qui
annonce une coopération
je traîne une image si on devait
s'appuyer ce tueur au il faudrait leur
demander une interopérabilité qui nous
permettent peut-être de faire des
modules complémentaires qui seraient des
modules souverain qui serait spécifique
à notre pemis a rejoint peut-être la ppl
que nous avions déposé il ya quelques
temps et voter cher cédric je vous
laisse répondre à sept premiers se
protéger de questions alors des
questions nombreuses alors je vais
essayer de ne pas être trop long même si
la personne qui dit s'appeler sur la
question de qui travaillent sur ce top
cow vide
donc trois organismes copilote au niveau
européen
école polytechnique fédérale de lausanne
pour la suisse la france et
cette manne s'agissant de la france
inria pilote une task force de
chercheurs et développeurs inria avec
une très forte implication
la direction de l'état notamment sur la
partie des bleus et de l'ansea
s'agissant de la question sécuritaire
évidemment relation respect des pensées
avec la cnil la taskforce piloté par
adria comprend des personnes qui
viennent du privé
les développeurs privés qui peut venir
de start up ou de grands groupes
français avec un élément qui est la base
de leur engagement qui le fait que les
personnes qui sont parties prenantes au
développement le fonds robben est donc
j'ai déjà dit plus à plusieurs reprises
nombre des développeurs parmi les
meilleurs du pays sont venus nous aider
en mettant à leur disposition leurs
compétences dans le développement de
l'application en disant je veux faire
moi même ma part du travail
je suis un très bon dos je viens vous
aider gratuitement
je n'ai pas
autorisation de ces personnes de révéler
leurs noms ni d'où elles viennent et
donc
à ce stade je ne communiquons pas sur
qui est impliqué il me semble que le
fait que ceci soit pro bono
que la propriété intellectuelle soit que
celle de l'état qui d'ailleurs s'est
engagé à mettre à disposition nos peines
source et le fait que le code soit
transparent est susceptible de donner
toutes les réassurance du fait qu'il
n'ya pas d'intérêt caché dans cette
cette opération et je veux au contraire
remercier tous ceux venant de grands
groupes venant de start up qui ont
décidé de venir nous aider
lorsqu'il ira dimension de projet
national de dix ans bah voilà chercheurs
je suis développeur je suis entreprise
je vous met à disposition des
développeurs piocher dedans autant que
vous voulez le temps que vous en aurez
besoin gratuitement et pour le bénéfice
que la collectivité veut les remercier
et je pense que
je ne vois pas de problème s'agissant
phase de développement
évidemment à un moment c'était
application devait voir le jour
il y aurait plein de questions qu'ils se
posent ré hébergement chance à la
rentrée dans un cours plus normal ou
d'abord développé cette application
faisant en sorte qu'elles aient toutes
les caractéristiques que j'ai évoqués et
je pense à me semble là la priorité
comment cela s'organise avec nos
partenaires vous avez raison d'évoquer
le fait que si l'on regarde ce qui se
passe dans la plupart des pays européens
pas tous mais la part des clients
européens ceux ci ont choisi l'une voit
un peu plus coercitives j avec notamment
très souvent l'utilisation des données
de géolocalisation afin de vérifier le
respect du confinement ce n'est pas le
choix qui a été choisie a été faire la
france est uniquement celui qui
travaille sur cette application stop&go
vide qui fait partie du projet européen
pe ppt petit nom espagne european
privacy préserver proxym it it racing et
qui fonctionne sur le bluetooth et le
volontariat le doute ou sept ans la
technologie une technologie qui a son
défaut qui est qu'effectivement elle n'a
pas été conçu pour mesurer la distance
alors que mesure de distance et au coeur
du fonctionnement d'applications pour
qualifier les quatre ce qui fait l'objet
du travail très intense que nous menons
avec les allemands qui ont un peu
d'avancé sur nous et nous met la
technologie du bluetooth a justement été
retenu parce que c'est la seule sur la
table en termes d'efficacité de respect
de la vie privée lieu est-ce que nous
allons réussir au final avoir quelque
chose soit suffisamment précis pour que
cela serve objectifs et publics
je ne suis pas totalement certain je
suis optimiste mais c'est tout le
travail que nous menons avec avec les
amis se pose une question sur le taux de
pénétration
je je je je veux prendre le temps d'y
répondre parce que
je pense qu'il faut ne pas comprendre
des objectifs
les données épidémiologiques sur la
question du taux de pénétration sont
assez diverses à différentes et
divergentes
le chiffre circule de entre 60 et 75 %
qui estiment que croit issus d'une étude
épidémiologique qui vient oxford et le
collège qui était la première sortie et
qui évoquait utiliser efficacité mais je
pense et c'est là qu'il faut faire le
lien avec aussi une question qui était
celle du signataire montaugé
tout dépend d'abord tout dépend de la
stratégie de déconfinement et de la
manière dont elle sera dont elle sera
menée
je prends un exemple je vous renvoie sur
la stratégie de confinement à l'audition
d'olivier ferrand ou de jean castex
c'est vraiment leur sujet donc je ne
fais que des projections
si jamais nous n'aurions des coûts ont
fini par zone alors la question se
poserait en zone jusque sur la
population française toute entière
et la deuxième chose je pense qu'il faut
vraiment l'avoir en tête c'est que
cette application viendra en plus
un travail qui doit être mené à la main
j insiste vraiment sur cet élément là le
travail de l'historique de proximité
d'abord être menées par des personnes
qui appellent les gens concernés
les interviews et retrace le sujet à la
main c'est c'est la recette magique
elle n'est pas magique elle est dans
cette architecture de personnes qui le
font à la main et c'est la recette
allemande et la recette coréenne est
donc cette application viendra en
surcroît de cette utilisation
et si elle vient en surcroît de cette
situation elle peut être très utile
mais à chaque fois que vous père
prévenez une personne de plus quelques
personnes de plus parce que la personne
qui est interviewé a oublié qu'elle
avait croisé telle personne parce que la
personne qui est interviewé est monté
dans un bus et que sur les quinze
personnes qu'elle a croisées dans le
buste 5 avec l'application à chaque fois
vous êtes capable de prévenir une
personne depuis ce qui doit aller se
faire tester
alors vous gagnez
prenez un temps d'avancé sur la chaîne
de transmission et donc
je préférerais si jamais nous devions
estimé qu'une application règles qu'elle
soit extrêmement largement diffusée dans
la population et je pense que c'est une
responsabilité que nous aurons de sorte
qu'elles soient le plus utilisé possible
et à chaque fois que quelqu'un laura ce
sera un contact de plus qui pourra être
touchée est prévenu charge à lui ou à l
évidemment de décider si elle veut aller
se faire tester et et c'est là que la
vraie raison il ya évidemment un lien
avec la stratégie de test un lien avec
la capacité à disposer de test et donc
c'est pour ça que je dis par ailleurs on
se voit dans une stratégie de
déconfinement qui est à la main
d'olivier veyrat et jean castex milk est
plus large cet outil il faut se garder
de de peur dans cette approche
technologique d'abord de la peur pour
les libertés publiques il me semble que
toutes les garanties sont données mais
également de la solution nice mais
technologique qui ne sera pas magique et
qui viendra par contre aidées
est ce que je peux juste constater c'est
que vraisemblablement au parlement
compte beaucoup sur sur cet outil
technologique
monsieur le sénateur montaugé sur la
question des dégâts femmes honnêtement
je je pense que c'est là ne cela ne
vient que confirmer beaucoup de choses
que vous aviez dit et que nous avions
dit que cela ne met encore plus en
valeur
j'espère que la prise de conscience
général des parties prenantes et de la
population on se retrouvera augmenté
ce que je constate malheureusement c'est
quand même que
cette vite à la facilité d'utilisation
utilisation que nous faisons aujourd'hui
zoom est assez révélatrice à cet égard
là
et donc je pense que ça pose la question
de manière encore plus aiguë mais je
pense que nous avons encore la nécessité
de gagner ce combat puisque
le constat est là
les actions qui relèvent du gouvernement
mais pas que du gouvernement je ne sens
pas dans la population française de
mouvement général pour aller vers
d'autres solutions que celles qui sont
facilement utilisables directement à
disposition alors que d'autres existent
les applications open source existe des
applications de visioconférence qui
marche très bien
peut-être pas totalement été bien
guillaume existe je ne sens pas de
mouvement général pour aller vers ces
versets outil c'est vrai d'ailleurs
l'état aussi jette la pierre à personne
réflexe d'aller vers ce qui marche le
mieux ce qui marche le mieux pour des
raisons historiques et pour des raisons
bassement cet américain aujourd'hui
souvent et donc il faut savoir que
si à un moment on veut des choix
européens il faudra accepter que pendant
quelques temps ça marche peut-être un
petit peu moins bien que ne soit pas
vraiment mais que ça marche soit un tout
petit peu moins agréable mais je pense
que c'est indispensable d'avoir cette
discussion et si la sita période peut
servir cela n'aura pas elle aura eu
certains même utilité à volonté c'est
que nous puissions communiquer sur l'
architecture technique dès que possible
d'écouter béton sous dix jours de telle
manière que l'on puisse dire ce que nous
avons en tête
quels sont les choix techniques que nous
avons fait qu'il puisse y avoir des
discussions entre une rihanna et
d'autres personnes
mais voilà je pense pas que contenu
dudit dates que nous avons vous et moi
en tête
si certains nous puissions avoir une
itération qui ne soit pas un peu en
parallèle dans la mesure où
après le 11 mai est un défi donc on sera
au rendez vous juste dernière fois
pardon sur la solidarité des géants du
numérique dans les faits si vous
regardez notamment le e-commerce
ils ne tirent pas du tout autant son
épingle du jeu pour le pense je pourrais
avoir eu des échanges avec les
commerçants français a notamment mais
aussi avec américain bien sûr on
pourrait considérer qu'ils font plus de
bénéfices dans la période
dans les faits ils rencontrent des
difficultés opérationnelles dans leur
entrepôt leurs livreurs qui font que la
décision d'amazon de ne livrer que les
biens essentiels et donc de se priver
d'une part de revenus
et est liée à leur incapacité à faire
face à d'autres une augmentation des
commandes c'est que ils ont eux mêmes
leurs problèmes de devrait organiser
leurs entrepôts c'est normal c'est
indispensable doivent le faire la
priorité c'est la protection mais il ne
faut pas voir en tout cas sur le
e-commerce la période comme une période
d'âge d'or de l'e commerce
dans les faits ils vont moins mal que
les autres et mais il n'y a pas de même
de pro je ne pense pas que l'on puisse
parler même de progression du chiffre
d'affaires ce n'est de toute évidence
d'autres services purement numérique en
profite je retiens votre idée de l'heure
de faire un appel aux dons pour le fonds
de solidarité je pense que ça va au delà
de responsabilité mais je pense que
rencontrer des gens seront très bien
très bien merci je vais maintenant
passer la parole à une dizaine de
collègues qui on demandait de vous poser
des questions va commencer par marie
noëlle lienemann ensuite serge babary
marie noëlle une fois que tu es sur ton
micro marine world en passant par la
mise
voilà vous ou au cynisme sur ce filet
tous les collègues j'espère que tout le
monde va bien je voudrais rebondir un
peu ce que vous voulez dire sur la
contribution des géants du numérique et
des plateformes qui aurait moins mal été
traités que d'autres commerces vous un
appel aux dons enfin j'espère que c'est
bien une contribution défini par la loi
parce que je crains que la salle aux
appels à la charité des de ces
entreprises ne soient pas suffisants au
regard de nos besoins et par ailleurs si
les e-commerce ont été moins impacté l
on était quand même à des années
lumières d'un certain nombre de petits
commerçants qui eux ont subi une forme
de concurrence déloyale qui justifierait
quand même une contribution spécifique
de ces plateformes pour le redressement
du pays que je distingue de la fiscalité
parce que la fiscalité on connaît les
débats qui sont en cours deuxième sujet
combien coûte actuellement
l'investissement de la france et du
budget de l'état dans la
mises en oeuvre ou d'inria structures
publiques dans la mise en oeuvre de
l'application stop qu'ovide parce que
quand je vois déjà pour ma part j'ai
quand même assez nébuleuse dans
l'explication
quand je lis les comptes rendus de ce
qui s'est passé vous expliquer c'est pas
la même méthode en corée etc
je ne suis pas sûr de l'efficacité
fabuleuse de cette affaire et comme
l'argent est assez rare je pense que je
voudrais qu'on sache combien ça coûte
parce que au regard de sa je préférerais
qu'on investisse à fond la caisse dans
la mise en oeuvre de tests en france qui
me semblent préalable à touches ainsi
que de masquer 2 troisième point les
critères de souveraineté numérique
alors moi je suis j'entends sans arrêt
le plaidoyer pour la souveraineté
numérique mais moi ce qui me préoccupe
maintenant c'est des actes je ne crois
pas qu'on va attendre par un soutien des
entreprises des collaborations si y'a
pas un volontarisme total de l'état la
puissance publique et des consortiums
européens créent nous n'y arriverons pas
si on n'avait pas eu des commandes
publiques orienté et un consortium
or le jeu du marché pour airbus on
l'aurait jamais fait vous prenez x
exemple en france de réussite alors je
suis pas forcément une fana du nucléaire
en fait s'il n'y avait pas de
volontarisme public pour engager la
filière nucléaire elle n'aurait jamais
vu le jour
donc il me semble que s'agissant des
outils des souverainetés des mairies si
je me réjouis que des licornes qui
émergent et qu'il faille de ferreux
prospérer je crois que sans une
planification un peu sérieuse des
endroits où on doit récupérer notre
souveraineté numérique par au moins au
démarrage
un appel public s'est enfin comment dire
un starter public quitte à ce qu'après
ça devienne un consortium moins
monomaniaque une public dont n'y
arriveront pas et par ailleurs par
rapport à ce que vous dites sur route le
citoyen ordinaire l'association lambda
la structure semi-publique elle ne
connaît pas les outils français même
s'ils sont moins bons mois je compte par
exemple plutôt que mou que google com
moteur de recherche c'est vrai qu'il ya
des fois je peste parce que c'est pas
tout à fait ce que je voudrais mais
néanmoins au moins une pour elle mettra
aucune information aucun volontarisme
d'état est l'exemple avait été donnée
pour la santé le truc qui s'appelle s
stars qui mâche un homme qui déjà bourse
appelle en anglais alors c'est un
système pour la france la santé de la
france donnait à microsoft
est-ce que vous n'êtes pas des regrets
sur des choses comme ça et ce n'est pas
maintenant
par exemple la ligne à l'image du small
business act un made in france ou made
in europe dans un premier temps
numérique encore je suis assez dubitatif
malgré tout sur la capacité à émerger
vie à des choses au niveau européen est
en tout cas qui ne met que dans les
appels d'offres on privilégie les outils
à caractère français et européens
parce que il ya sept ans il ya
l'intervention publique
les appels d'offres qui doivent être
prioritairement pouvoir et
prioritairement orientés vers 6h faire
ces outils là et la bonne connaissance
par le public des outils français ou
open source qui peuvent exister
aujourd'hui comme on dit qu'il faut
apprendre le numérique ces gens il faut
qu'on leur apprenne à choisir français
et choisir européen et marie noëlle la
crj babarit à un sud jean-pierre manga
merci président bonjour monsieur le
ministre je souhaiterais poser de
questions sur le numérique et le
commerce de proximité
tout d'abord le gouvernement a obtenu
d'un certain nombre d'acteurs du
e-commerce qu'ils proposent des tarifs
préférentiels afin de permettre aux
commerçants de proximité de poursuivre
autant que possible leurs activités en
recourant au numérique
c'est évidemment une initiative
bienvenue cependant on trouve sur cette
liste des grands noms tels que rakuten
cdiscount ou leboncoin
mais pas amazon on retrouve là la
remarque de mon collègue franck montaugé
ne manque de solidarité
pourquoi une telle absence c'est une
question banale mais je pense que c'est
anormal
à chaque occasion de voir que ce grand
groupe est absent de des efforts des uns
et des autres 2
j'aime question si on veut parler
d'après la crise sur la numérisation des
entreprises pour réduire la fracture
numérique entre commerce en ligne et
commerces de proximité commerces
physiques initiative ans nîmes va t elle
être renforcée
on pourrait imaginer par exemple de
proposer sur amortissements dédié à la
présence en ligne
qu'en pensez vous merci dominique
estrosi sassone ensuite viser à
martigues à l'ast oui montant des vols
et monsieur bonjour madame la présidente
et bonjour à tous on connaît alors annie
guillemot qui anime avec mois de suivi
sur le logement
je ne prenais pas présente dans notre
bout du riob parce qu'elles étaient
retenus sur une autre visioconférence il
y a deux points qui sont montés deux
auditions concernant le numérique dans
le domaine de l'immobilier est le
numérique sera forcément encore plus
demain un puissant facteur de
productivité et de transversalité qui
décloisonne grand encore les métiers
mais cette crise sanitaire monsieur le
ministre a montré également la
considérable insuffisance de
dématérialisation à tous les niveaux de
la chaîne du logement depuis la
conception du projet en passant par les
demandes d'autorisation de permis de
construire ou d'urbanisme la production
la construction la commercialisation
mais aussi la gestion locative des
transactions et la maintenance tous les
segments problème du logement ne sont
pas au même niveau
le secteur privé je pense plus
particulièrement à la promotion
immobilière est aujourd'hui pratiquement
équipe est à 100% mais le secteur public
ne l'est pas ou trop peu et cela crée
inévitablement le réel blocage
je pense en particulier à la
dématérialisation des demandes de permis
de construire une autorisation
d'urbanisme et monsieur le ministre est
ce que vous comptez de ce point de vue
accélérer le processus de
dématérialisation et y compris auprès
des services de l'état qui sont loin de
cette dématérialisation attendu il ya
aussi les collectivités
mais les services de l'état
je pense en tant qu'emploi et donc de ce
fait accélérer le projet 2022 et puis je
pourrais aussi parler de l'hébergement
d'urgence parce que la crise sanitaire a
été le révélateur à la puissance 10 de
tous les dysfonctionnements dans le
monde de l'hébergement d'urgence et la
fracture numérique
la fracture des usages montre encore
combien cela et quand en plus prégnant
auprès des publics qui sont dans
l'hébergement d'urgence
maintenant les associations qui
s'occupent de ces buts là nous disait
que plus particulièrement pour les
familles
et bien cette fracture numérique fait
que les enfants sont de ce fait
complètement déscolarisés et que même si
l'association
dans cette période de crise sanitaire
vont avoir à faire des investissements
supplémentaires pour d'autres par
exemple les centres d'hébergement
d'urgence d'équipements informatiques
cela va inévitablement entraîner un
surcoût alors que leur budget sont déjà
extrêmement contraint enfin je voudrais
simplement dire que lille à 14 start-up
assurés qui ont répondu à votre appel
monsieur le ministre pour aider les
français à faire face à la situation
exceptionnelle liée à l'épidémie du
comique 19 et elle propose effectivement
aux acteurs de la santé aux entreprises
ou encore au grand public de pouvoir
utiliser leurs services gratuitement
pendant cette période de confinement je
pense que ça aussi c'est un beau message
de solidarité revente
merci beaucoup merci dominique cavigal
artigalas ensuite alain durand merci
madame la présidente mes chers collègues
monsieur le ministre vous l'avez dit
vous avez dit monsieur le ministre dans
cette période de crise cela nous montre
bien l'importance des usages du
numérique tels que les tenue de réunions
les transmissions le partage et le
stockage des informations et données
continuer à faire fonctionner notre
société la question va être un petit peu
complémentaire de celles de marie-noëlle
lienemann
est-ce que vous avez un plan de
développement et de promotion doute paix
rhdp quand ces usages en tout simple qui
soit simple et efficace mais aussi
qu'ils soient secure est confidentiel
qui respecte la confidentialité de nos
données et au moins nous
institutions et les services de l'état
ma deuxième question porte sur la santé
j'ai vu que les citoyens engagés dans la
conférence de la convention citoyenne
politiquement remettez en cause le
déploiement de la csg parce que ben il
s'était un peu des environnements palais
mais aussi parce qu'il n'apportait rien
de plus dont nous avons besoin
habituellement ces temps de crise donc
c'était passé certes aller plus loin
merci fabien gay une suisse daniel
grenier président bonjour monsieur le
ministre
j'espère que m'entendais toutes et tous
parce que vous allez bien que l'acteur
numérique ça existe pour le coup je suis
désolé ça fait trois fois que ça
j'espère à l'oumma qui sont à monsieur
le ministre
j'avais de location mais vous avez
répondu sur le track id partage parce
que le débat entre nous doit continuer
je sais qu'on va l'avoir au parlement je
pense que c'est une commission
évidemment très complexe dans la période
il faut que nous allions au bout de ce
débat parce que ça me pose beaucoup de
questions comme la belle avait dit ça
peut être une des solutions mais elle
doit aussi s'accompagner débat
démocratique sur l'été sur libertés
politiques
donc je reviens pas la deuxième question
c'est pour appuyer ce que disait
franquet et notamment marie noëlle moi
je pense que dans la période quand même
même si j'entends ce que vous dites
qu'on est plate forme numérique et le
e-commerce père il ya quand même une
distorsion de concurrence avec nos
commerçants de physique ils peuvent
livrer là où nos commerces sont
aujourd'hui fermées et ajuste raison
donc nous revenons pas mais même s'ils
perdent du chiffre d'affaires par
exemple amazon a gagné la dernière
semaine du mois de mars d'affaires 200
euros son action a pris à la bourse
donc il ya une vraie question est d'une
distorsion de concurrence
et il ya une question du droit des
salariés qu'il est ailleurs viennent de
gagner savez à 14h en référé
amazon est assignée sous 24 heures à ne
livrer que les produits essentiels
alimentaire hygiène et médicales donc ce
n'est pas qu'ils ont souhaité ils ont
été mis en référé et les salariés ont
gagné parce que dans les grands
entrepôts notamment à brétigny et
ailleurs il est impossible de respecter
les gestes barrière donc c'est une vraie
question
donc moi j'abonde il ya deux choses je
pense que tant que nous ne serons pas la
sécurité de l'ensemble des salariés
il ya une injonction contradictoire
alors dire rester confiné mais aller où
si nous ne sommes pas en capacité de
respecter et de mettre des normes 5
il est très compliqué et la deuxième moi
je ne suis pas pour le monde je pense
qu'il faut légiférer sur cette question
il faut que ces grandes plateformes
numériques qui en plus sont des
champions de l'optimisation fiscale
parce que tout le débat que nous avons
je le met pas de côté et je ne parle pas
de la taxe d'affamés du combat que vous
menez au niveau européen mais dans la
période
il faut donc qu'on leur demande une
contribution pour le fonds d'urgence
pour nos commerçants jeu parce que là ça
serait une proposition que nous
pourrions dès la semaine prochaine
débattre au parlement dans le budget
rectificatif
je pense que c'est une question de
justice sociale voilà je vous remercie
merci fabien nous terminons par daniel
gremillet si d'autres personnes veulent
prendre la parole je vous rappelle qu'il
faut utiliser ou converser en bas à
droite merci oui il ya main présente le
soliste chers collègues
moi je voulais revenir sur le sujet la
télémédecine
vous avez beaucoup évoqué tout à l'heure
dans votre propos monsieur le ministre
alors mon propos n'est pas négative mais
mon propos est plutôt attirer votre
attention et notamment j'ai eu un
certain nombre de témoignages de
médecins est aujourd'hui des
conséquences que ça apporte aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui on a 40% de l'activité de la
médecine générale qui est a disparu est
aujourd'hui à sa tante de le patient qui
avait besoin d'être suivi disparu des
radars et notamment par rapport à la
propagande qu'on a fait sur les bêtises
sur le fait qu il passe et j'en suis au
m
etc mais c'est pas là je me sens tout
insisté monsieur le ministre c'est sur
le fait aujourd'hui que des plateformes
de les médecines commencent à se monter
dans des pays étrangers
les lois évoluent avec ta question de la
responsabilité pénale des médecins liés
à télémédecine lors des maîtres des
pharmaciens fait évoluer son code de l
état afin de préparer le futur de grands
gourmands des types en jetant un grand
nombre de pharmaciens de pharmacies
vendent henin un témoignage d'un des
médecins qui dit concernant mon métier
l'état
attaqué de toutes parts à grands coups
de millions et de campagnes de
communication des acteurs devenus
incontournables nous ce père is
progressivement finances étant un cran
assureurs le site de télémédecine
j'utilise prend une commission de 5
euros à consultation ce qui est
proportionnellement supérieure aux frais
de fonctionnement du cabinet qui
comprend comme vous le savez trois
médecins et deux secrétaires les sites
de prise de rendez-vous sont en ligne se
livrent une guerre de référencement sur
google qui fait que si l'on veut être
visible nous sommes obligés de rejoindre
auditeurs le simple fait d'être puni par
arnaud patient à un prix 139 euros par
mois sans oublier et vouliez d'y ajouter
70 euros par mois pour avoir accès aux
modules de téléconsultation ces coûts
sont totalement démesurée et il serait
intéressant de voir combien coûte
réellement les frais de télé le
développement être fonctionnement de
cette application qui sont des plus
basiques
ma question est simple c'est une
remarque mais c'est c'est de vous dire
tout simplement une ce ministre faisons
attention le côté humain à sa place et
on soigne pas uniquement l'homme avec un
grand h avec des algorithmes
sange le dernier l'a très bien je ne
vois pas d'autres demandes de prise de
parole et donc je me laissais toutes ces
questions monsieur le ministre votre
micro question la sénatrice marie noëlle
lienemann
combien coûte le développement
d'applications stop qu'ovide
zéro euro en dehors aujourd'hui des
salaires des chercheurs d'inria des
personnes de l'anssi et des personnes de
l'adie nul qui sont impliqués je ne sais
pas vous dire très honnêtement il
contrôle et gestion bureaucratique de du
développement de l'application n'a pas
hésité notre priorité pour le dire très
honnêtement mais il n'y a que des
personnes des fonctionnaires et des gens
qui travaillent et gratuite
donc je dois donner quelques dizaines de
milliers d'euros voire quelques
centaines de milliers d'euros
rien de plus sur la question des tests
j'ai eu l'occasion de répondre sur le
fait que tout cela nécessite
sur la souveraineté européenne qui n'est
pas sans lien avec la commande publique
notamment
c'est vrai je me permets toutefois une
remarque c'est que nous ne développons
pas le numérique comme nous développons
que nous avons pu faire des grands
projets sur le nucléaire ou les airbus
une application de l'état et être
capable de faire des outils qui sont
adoptées par le public seuls les
entrepreneurs savent le faire seuls les
entrepreneurs savent le faire et
d'ailleurs si vous regardez toutes les
entreprises qui font des produits qui
marchent et qui sont adoptés
elles sont le fait d'un entrepreneur qui
peuvent être largement aidées par l'état
mais que ce soit chez les chinois ou les
américains sont des entrepreneurs qui
savent le faire ceux ci doivent être
pensés en lien avec les ans ça ne peut
pas être une étatisation du numérique et
des projets numériques et donc il faut
le penser en lien avec nous avec des
entrepreneurs et des entreprises
et oui nous avons besoin partenariat
public privé si je puis me permettre ce
terme juridique en l'espèce un pour
faire en sorte que mission à mener le
projet à bien
sur la question du recours par elsa
table donc lente auprès de santé à
microsoft et je sais que vous dire si ce
n'est que c'est l'illustration même
d'une partie de retard technologique que
nous avons pris
il n'y avait pas d'option française est
là la priorité de sujets et de faire en
sorte que nous puissions faire tourner
les algorithmes d'intelligence a noté
jean sociales qui permettent
par exemple de découvrir les
interactions médicamenteuses et un
certain nombre de pattern sur qui
permettent de lutter contre le coc vide
du d'équivalent français à ce que je
fais dans le groupe loud microsoft
google ou amazon je le regrette
profondément profondément mais sur
certaines briques technologiques
notamment par des techniques mais le
passé le sas posez la question à
n'importe quel afin d'être ici en
français il vous répondra très
clairement est-ce qu'il faut que pour
faire en sorte que la france les années
qui viennent
bon je le pense
c'est absolument indispensable est ce
qu'aujourd'hui nous avons une
alternative non je me dis très
clairement on a des très bons les
personnes qui sur les infrastructures
comme ovh week-end d'autres sont très
forts sur certaines couches
technologiques
nous sommes très long
monsieur le sénateur obama arrive sur
des questions je fais ne tuez permettre
de vous répondre sur la question france
nue mais la question du e-commerce
j'entends beaucoup d'entre vous évoquez
la distorsion de concurrence entre le
commerce physique et le commerce en
ligne dans la période
je rappelle que amazon france ces 20 %
du commerce en ligne
cinquième c'est à dire beaucoup moins
que notamment en allemagne dans les
autres pays européens où c'est entre eux
+ 40 % voire plus de 50%
80% du commerce en ligne est fait par
d'autres plateformes que la zone
notamment des plateformes françaises
notamment des e-commerçants français
comme cdiscount com à nouveau comme
darty qui en ligne comme plein d'autres
dispersants qui sont engagés qui font
très bon travail
le
la distorsion de concurrence qui existe
en ce moment
la faute d'amazon
et parce que collectivement
comparativement aux autres pays
européens
nos pme ne vendent pas assez sur
internet est la vraie solution peut pas
reprocher amazon que nos pme ne vont pas
sur internet et que les gens quand ils
sont confinés
comment sur internet qu'il faut faire en
sorte c'est qui est beaucoup plus de
concurrence est beaucoup plus de
français qui vendent effectivement sur
internet et c'est là que je fais le lien
avec la question qui se pose c'est
qu'est ce qu'on fait tous ensemble
les les associations d'organes
professionnelle l'état les collectivités
territoriales pour aider nos commerçants
à vendre sur internet
il n'y a pas d'alternative à aller sur
internet aujourd'hui dans une période de
confinement et heureusement qu'on a des
e-commerçants qui sont là pour essayer
de vendre faute de quoi pour même pour
les petits commerces ces problématiques
et et je reviens avec eux éléments qui
étaient les parrains
j'ai perdu non l'un d'entre vous qui
disait il
qui mentionnait l'initiative qui a été
la nôtre qui était de demander et de
faire la promotion auprès des petits
commerçants qu'ils aillent vente sur les
plateformes
aujourd'hui si vous voulez aller vendre
sur sur internet
c'est très compliqué de faire votre site
par contre certaines plateformes c'est
discale le bon coin vous propose de
vendre sur internet c'est pareil qu'il
faut passer et donc nous avons mis en
place une action qui fait que les petits
comme vous pouvez retrouver par le nom
de votre petit commerçant de votre
libraire de votre magasin de vêtements
de wau pas votre adresse
autour de vous les petits commerçants
qui vendent sur sur les plateformes
d'entre vous évoqué le fait est que le
fait qu amazon pas voulu ça john se
joindre à cette action et est
problématique
je vais le prendre à la baisse cela il
faut que les e-commerçants français
utilise le fait que les français peuvent
retrouver leurs petits commerces sur
leur plate forme et pas sur amazon pour
justement gagner des parts de marché et
quelque part je pense que c'est une très
bonne chose mais je tiens tout ça parce
que
il y a quelque chose d'un peu étonnant
de parler de distorsion de concurrence
non le vrai problème c'est que nous
n'avons pas assez de pme qui vont sur
internet mais n'y a pas d'autre manière
que de vendre sur internet et à distance
dès lors que vous êtes complètement le
problème c'est que la question n'est pas
de mettre des barrières contre pacifique
la question et offensif est de faire en
sorte que nous soyons aussi bons que les
autres
très bien merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre on voit dans vos propos je
trouve difficile équilibre que nous pose
cette situation mais que nous révèle
cette situation s'est équilibrée
peut-être déjà difficile à trouver
auparavant entre le numérique et le
physique sur la partie médicale menée de
l'évoquer sur la partie commerciale
serge babary et d'autre on en parle et
c'est comment on vit ce monde après avec
le numérique en l'incluant et non pas en
excluant les uns ou les autres
une question d'évolution de la société
qui va bien au delà de la gestion de
cette crise voilà pour cette audition de
cédric au le secrétaire d'état chargé du
numérique qui a été auditionnée en
visioconférence par la commission des
affaires économiques du sénat il s'est
avant tout exprimer sur ce projet
d'application stop qu'ovide et on l'a
bien compris il ne s'agit que d'un
projet pour l'instant la faisabilité
même de l'application est encore en
question néanmoins et bien vous l'avez
entendu le secrétaire d'état au
numérique a tenté de rassurer sur toutes
les craintes que peuvent avoir les
sénateurs en matière de libertés
individuelles notamment vous pouvez
toujours voir et revoir toutes les
auditions sur notre site publicsenat.fr
très bonne journée sur les chaînes
parlementaires
[Musique]